hi everyone
this is professor m das science and
today we're going to talk about the
displacement operator
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics the mathematical
expression for the displacement operator
involves the exponential function of the
sum of the ladder operators of the
quantum harmonic oscillator so at first
sight it might appear a rather obscure
operator
but we're going to learn today that it
actually plays a crucial role in the
study of coherent states
in particular we will see that we can
generate a coherent state
by applying the displacement operator of
the ground state
of the quantum harmonic oscillator it
also plays a very important role in
other areas most notably
quantum optics and so with this in mind
today what we're going to do is explore
the mathematical properties
of this displacement operator so let's
go
the displacement operator is defined in
the context of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
so let's start with a quick refresher
the quantum harmonic oscillator is
characterized by the hamiltonian h
that has the standard kinetic energy
term
and whose potential energy depends
quadratically on the position operator
we can also write down this hamiltonian
in terms of ladder operators
or in terms of the number operator
we can also write the eigenvalue
equation of the hamiltonian of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
where these are the eigenvalues and
these are the eigen states
the eigenvalues en are quantized and
equal to h bar omega
times n plus one half where n must be a
non-negative integer
the associated eigenstate n can be
constructed by acting
n times with the rating operator on the
ground state
finally the latter operators allow us to
move
between eigenstates in particular the
lowering operator acts on eigenstate n
to give a new term that is proportional
to eigenstate
n minus one so that it lowers the energy
of the state
by one quantum and the raising operator
acts on eigenstate n to give a new term
proportional to eigenstate n plus one
raising the energy of the state by one
quantum
this was just a very quick refresher on
the quantum harmonic oscillator but you
can follow the links in the description
for a more in-depth discussion of these
ideas
we're now ready to define the
displacement operator
we define the displacement operator d by
an amount alpha
as equal to the exponential of alpha
a dagger minus alpha star
a in this expression alpha is a complex
scalar
at this point the name displacement
operator may appear somewhat
arbitrary but we'll discover later on in
the video
why this operator has this precise name
the plan for the rest of the video is
pretty simple
first we will go over a few properties
of the displacement operator
including why it has this name and
second
we will explain how it is related to
coherent state of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
but before we do that we will write the
displacement operator in a slightly
different form
remember from the video on functions of
operators that if we have
two operators a and b such that a
commute with a commutator of
a and b and b also commutes with the
commutator of a
and b then we have that the exponential
of a plus
b is equal to the exponential of a
times the exponential of b times the
exponential
of minus one half times the commutator
of a and b this is a special case of the
baker campbell house door formula
and again if you want more details we
actually first introduced it in our
video on functions of operators so you
can watch that
in our case the ladder operators obey
this computation relation
and as their commutator is a scalar then
we immediately have
that a commutes with a commutator of
a and a dagger
and a dagger also commutes with the same
commutator
this means that the conditions under
which this formula up here
is valid apply in our case and we can
therefore
write the displacement operator which we
originally defined as the exponential of
a sum
as the exponential of the first term
times the exponential of the second term
times the exponential of minus one-half
times
their commutator if we focus
on this commutator for a moment we can
write it down
and we can then simplify it by taking
the scalars outside the commutator
this product here is simply the absolute
value squared of alpha
and this commutator here is equal to -1
so that we end up with the absolute
value squared
of alpha overall this means that we can
write
the displacement operator as equal to
the exponential of the rating operator
the exponential of the lowering operator
and
this scalar exponential the scalar
exponential can meet with all of the
terms so we can rewrite
this expression in the conventional form
which includes the
scalar exponential first
in general both this original definition
up here
and this rewritten form down here will
prove
useful when working with the
displacement operator
the first property i want to look at is
that the displacement operator
is unitary to show this we first need to
consider
the add joint of the displacement
operator
from the video on functions of operators
we know that
the add joint of an exponential function
is equal to the exponential of the add
joint
and this is true because the exponential
function is
a real function using this we can now
pick this expression
for the displacement operator and write
the at joint of the displacement
operator as the exponential of the at
joint
using a similar derivation to the one
that we used
just a minute ago we can separate this
expression into an exponential of the
scalar
alpha multiplying an exponential of the
lowering operator
and an exponential of the racing
operator
now a question for you before we move on
try to convince yourself
that this expression is consistent with
the adjoint of this expression
with the three exponentials here
okay so moving on with these results we
can evaluate
the product of d with d dagger
copying this expression for d we get
these three terms
and copying this expression for d dagger
we get these three terms
the two scalar exponentials cancel here
and here
this term and this term combine to the
identity
and this is true because the exponents
commute so we can combine them straight
away
and then this term and this term also
combine to the identity
for the same reason so overall we get
the identity operator
using a similar approach d dagger time
d is also equal to the identity
putting these together we see that the
add joint of the displacement operator
is equal to the inverse so that the
displacement operator
is a unitary operator
the next property i want to consider is
the displacement operator
d of minus alpha using the definition of
the displacement operator
up here we can write this out as the
exponential of minus
alpha a dagger plus alpha star a
by simply replacing alphas by minus
alphas
the next step is to change the order of
the sum
in the exponent which we can do because
addition of operators
is commutative comparing this latest
result
with this expression up here for the
adjoint operator
we see that they're the same
overall from the previous line we have
that the d dagger alpha
is equal to the inverse of d alpha and
from this slide we have that it is also
equal to d
of minus alpha this means that the
inverse of
a displacement by alpha is simply a
displacement
by minus alpha
the next relation i want to prove is
that the product of
two displacement operators d alpha and d
beta
is equal to a phase factor times another
displacement operator
alpha plus beta to prove this
we will start with a displacement
operator of alpha plus beta
writing out this operator we get this
very long exponential
we're now going to use the baker
campbell house door formula yes again
and in this case this is the a operator
and this is the b operator so we get
this exponential that depends on alpha
this exponential that depends on beta
and the exponential of the commutator
this is the displacement operator d
alpha
and this here is the displacement
operator d beta
for the communicator here let's first
copy it
the only non-zero terms are those
involving the cross computator of a
a dagger which are this one
and this one
this is equal to -1 and this is equal to
one
so we end up with alpha beta star minus
alpha star beta
using this result we can write the
displacement operator
d alpha plus beta as equal to d
alpha times d beta times this scalar
exponential
and this confirms the result up here
it turns out that this property is the
key to understanding
the name displacement operator but more
on that later
i now want to look at commutators
let's start with the commutator of the
lowering operator with the displacement
operator
using this form of the displacement
operator
we can rewrite this expression to get
this new commutator
we can then take out the scalar
exponential multiplying the commutator
of the remaining terms
at this point we remember the formula of
the commutator of an operator with a
product of two other operators
which is equal to these two terms
and which we proved in the video on
commutator algebra
using this formula we get the scalar
exponential
and then the first term
plus the second term
from the video on functions of operators
we know that
any operator commutes with a function of
itself
so this first commutator vanishes
and if you don't remember this result it
simply arises because the function of an
operator
is given by the power series of the
function and
any operator commutes with a power of
itself
this second commutator is trickier and
to evaluate it we need another result
from the video on functions of operators
if we have two apparatus a and b such
that a commutes with their commutator
and b also commutes with their
commutator
then the commutator of a with a function
f of b
is equal to the commutator of a with b
times the derivative of the function of
b
in our case a and b are the ladder
operators and we've already established
earlier
that they obey these two conditions
because the commutator is equal to the
scalar one
this means that we can use this result
here straight away
overall we get the scalar exponential
then we use the result we've just
discussed where the function
f in our case is the exponential
function
giving first commutator of a with a
dagger
times the derivative of the exponential
which is
alpha times v exponential and then we
still have the final exponential of the
lowering operator
this commutator is equal to 1
and then combining the scalar
exponential with these two exponentials
here
we see that they are simply the
displacement operator
so overall the commutator of a with d
alpha
is equal to alpha d alpha
similarly we could calculate the
commutator of a dagger with a
displacement operator
and the result is alpha star d alpha
as a final property before we move on to
the relation to coherent states
i want to consider the unitary
transformation of the ladder operators
if you need a refresher about unitary
transformations
you can find the corresponding video
links in the description
but the most important property is that
they conserve
the norm of quantum states and as such
are used to describe physical processes
such as spatial transformations
or time evolution in our case
we consider d dagger alpha a
d alpha this is called the unitary
transformation of
a with respect to the displacement
operator
to evaluate this expression we start
with the commutator up here
which i first copied down here
this computation implies that a d alpha
is equal to
d alpha a plus alpha d alpha
using this result we can rewrite the
unitary transformation as
equal to d dagger alpha multiplying
these two terms
and multiplying through we get this
first term
and this second term where i move the
scalar to the
end as the displacement operator is
unitary
this here is the identity and so is this
overall we get a plus
alpha using a similar derivation
we would conclude that the unitary
transformation of the rating operator
is equal to a dagger plus alpha star
to finish i want to explore the relation
between
the displacement operator and coherent
states
for a full refresher about coherent
states you can find
the corresponding video in the
description
coherent states are defined as the
eigenstates of the lowering operator
the key result that i want to explore is
that we can write
a coherent state alpha as equal to the
application of the displacement operator
d
alpha on the ground state of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
to prove this result we only need to
consider the action of the lowering
operator
on the state formed by d alpha acting on
the ground state
we again consider the commutator of a
with d alpha up here
which we first copy down here
this commutator implies that a d alpha
is equal to d alpha a plus alpha d alpha
using this expression we can rewrite the
action of a
on d alpha 0 as equal to these two terms
acting on the ground state we can expand
this
into the term proportional to the
lowering operator
plus the term proportional to alpha
the lowering operator kills the ground
state so we end up
with alpha multiplying d alpha
acting on the ground state
we therefore see that a acting on this
state
gives the scalar alpha times the same
state
and this confirms that d alpha 0
is an eigen state of the lowering
operator with eigenvalue
alpha so that we can generate the
coherent state alpha
by the application of the displacement
operator on the ground state
as shown up here in the video on
coherent states we define them as eigen
states of the lowering operator
this relation that we've just derived
using the action of the displacement
operator on the ground state
is actually an alternative but
equivalent definition
for coherence states what this means
is that we could define a coherent state
in terms of the displacement operator
and then
the fact that coherent states are eigen
states of the lowering operator
could be derived from it
and we're now finally ready to
understand
the origin of the name of the
displacement operator
as we said earlier we will use this
relation describing the consecutive
application of two displacement
operators by amount
alpha and beta which is equal to a phase
factor
times the displacement by alpha plus
beta
let's consider a coherent state alpha
given by the displacement by alpha
of the ground state let's now consider
what happens when we apply the
displacement operator d beta
on this coherent state we first get d
beta times the coherence state in terms
of d
alpha and the ground state using this
relation up here
we can rewrite this as this phase factor
times the displacement operator d alpha
plus beta
acting on the ground state and this here
is simply the coherence state alpha plus
beta
what does this mean the application of
the operator d beta on a coherent state
alpha
gives an irrelevant phase factor and
then
generates another coherent state that is
displaced by
beta compared to the original one
so this is the reason why we call this
the displacement operator
these displacement may appear somewhat
abstract and
they are so don't worry if it takes some
time to gain
the intuition about them just to give
you an example of how abstract they are
in the context of quantum optics they
are displacements
in the optical phase space
the displacement operator is central in
our study of coherent states
to see an example of its use i encourage
you to take a look at the video on
coherent states wave functions
in which the displacement operator is
absolutely key to build
these wave functions i hope that you
liked the video and as always please
subscribe